j'ai tellement de
défauts que tu peux pas reprocher grand
chose aux autres pas reprocher grand
chose aux autres
voilàors Richard tu as entendu parler du
questionnaire de prou ou qui en fait
n'est pas de prou contrairement à ce que
tout le monde croit c'est un jeu de
société français qui date de l'époque de
Napoléon I tu auras appris un truc c'est
fou ce qu'on apprend comme truc dans
cette émission c'est fau ouais c'est
[Musique]
FA
pour quelle faute as-tu le plus
d'indulgence la peur ton peintre favori
Charles maton ton pote ce celui qui t'a
trouvé en plus qui t'a fait faire ton
premier film Charles maton ouais mais
c'est mon maître spirituel c'est pas
c'est c'est mon ami c'est mon père c'est
plein de choses comme ça
mais la question c'était mon pote favori
non ton peintre mon peintre favori
Charles mon ouais oua Charles maton
Charles maton ta vertu
préférée
vertu
vertu je sais pas ce que c'est avec la
vertu ton occupation préférée la vie le
principal trait de ton caractère
emmerdeur ton poète favori
r c'est le même que JAAC sauf que toi tu
l'as
peut-être
non non mais je pense qu'il l'a lu on
peut pas on peut pas non non je pense
qu'il a lu puis même si on n pas
d'accord sur certaines choses on peut
être d'accord sur d'autres non ou je ve
dire bah bien sûr sur la poésie ça
rapproche les hommes s'il aime en échar
rien n'est perdu rien perdu ce que tu
détestes par-dessus
tout j'ai tellement de
défaut que tu peux pas reprocher grand
chose aux autr reprocher grand chose aux
autres voilà alors
euh c'est alors moi le défaut que j'aime
le moins quoi ouais des trucs que tu
peux pas saquer quand même chez les gens
trucs qui te gonfle à mort bah je
croyais jusque il y a quelques années je
croyais que la frim c'était un truc qui
métait insupportable et puis je me suis
aperçu que la frim ça pouvait être aussi
la façon que les êtres aident de vivre
des rêves même s'ils sont futiles même
s'ils sont alors je oh le défaut c'est
ça serait quoi euh parce que tu
supportes pas e bah ça veut dire si je
prête 10 sac qu'on me téléphone pas pour
me dire je peux pas te les rendre benah
voilà maintenant que tu es riche t'en
prête beaucoup de l'argent je suis pas
riche bon écoute quand on vend 330000
exemplaires d'un bouquin on est pas
pauvre quand même non ah non on est pas
pauvre ça par rapport à un mec qui gagne
5000 balles par mois c'est sûr qu'on est
pas euh par rapport au mec de péchiner
tu es pas riche riche riche quoi c'est
sûr ouais c'est sûr ouais par rapport
par rapport à l'avenir je suis pas riche
non plus je suis riche de mes
espérancesespoir tu as une
devise
ouais je l'ai pas toujours mise en
pratique toujours mise en pratique
j'aimerais ne pas être infidèle à
moimême et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater debe abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu